bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle
Véronique prince je suis correspondante
parlementaire pour Radio-Canada depuis
2012 et je fais partie des caravaniers
qui suit cette campagne électorale au
jour le jour et aujourd'hui on fait ce
Facebook live pour pouvoir répondre à
vos questions parce qu'on voit qu'elles
sont nombreuses sur les différents
réseaux sociaux vous voulez savoir un
petit peu comment se passe notre vie de
caravani et c'est normal on va être là
pour vous l'expliquer je vais vous
présenter en fait mes quatre collègues
on peut peut-être commencer par
jean-caudrey si tu veux te présenter aux
gens je m'appelle Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau je suis journaliste à
Radio-Canada au Téléjournal et j'en suis
à ma première campagne et depuis deux
semaines je couvre je suis en fait la
caravane de Québec solidaire et je vais
bientôt passer à partir de ce soir au
conservateur
[Musique]
depuis le début je suis donc la caravane
pékiste avec Paul Saint-Pierre flamandon
et là je vais prendre la place de
Jacques Audrey dans le bus des
solidaires d'ailleurs je pense que c'est
important de spécifier que c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'on est
sainte parce qu'habituellement pour
faire ces Facebook live là les autres
campagnes on était deux trois
caravaniers mais on voit vraiment que ça
a changé l'axe souverainiste fédéraliste
c'est complètement différente on se
retrouve avec des parties sur tout le
spectre politique et c'est pour ça qu'on
est cinq aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
particulier de faire cette conversation
là à 5 et ce sera en évidence ce soir au
face à face la première chose télévisée
de la campagne 5 chefs ça fera pas
beaucoup de temps pour exposer ses idées
de la cacophonie pour pouvoir faire
attention à ça mais justement ça m'amène
à me dire aux gens qui peuvent nous
poser des questions en temps réel on va
les prendre et tout ça puis je vois que
la première question de France Gagnon
tombe à point là parce que vous avez
tous nommé sur quel caravane vous étiez
les deux la semaine sur quelle caravane
vous allez les deux prochaines puis
justement elle nous demande est-ce que
vous changez de caravane en milieu de
campagne la réponse si oui mais je pense
qu'on pourrait expliquer pourquoi en
fait c'est important de changer de
caravane c'est important pour plusieurs
raisons René parce qu'on s'habitue à
travailler avec les mêmes personnes on
est très près aussi on devient prêt et
du chef et de de son staff politique
puis un moment donné on a plus
nécessairement en plus la vision
d'ensemble parce qu'on est dans une
bulle c'est un peu seul on est vraiment
comme dans notre bulle puis on a pas
toujours le temps quand on arrive à 11h
le soir de récupérer toutes les
bulletins nouvelles qui sont faits on
n'a pas donc là ça nous faut vraiment
repartir à neuf pour être pour assurer
je pense la meilleure équipe d'autres
questions aussi parfois c'est de pouvoir
poser d'avoir un regard un peu extérieur
puis de pouvoir poser d'autres questions
au chef je pense que le changement de
caravane même si j'en suis à ma première
ça peut amener ça un regard un peu plus
frais sur une campagne qui qui des fois
repart à nouveau avec un rendez-vous
comme ce soir un débat tout ça on remet
le compteur à zéro donc on le veuille ou
non je pense aussi que le chef finit par
s'habituer un petit peu au journaliste
qui sont à bord de l'autobus au style
des journalistes des fois ils voient un
petit peu les questions venir et on le
sent donc après deux semaines d'aller
changer de caravane comme ça je pense
que c'est aussi déstabilisant pour les
chefs qui vont devoir s'habituer à des
nouveaux styles de questions peut-être
des angles auxquels il y avait pas été
exposé jusqu'à maintenant j'en profite
pour saluer madame Gagnon qui m'écrit de
temps en temps sur Twitter d'ailleurs
les gens qui nous écrivent mais ça
permet de changer d'air de dans
l'autobus parce que à un moment donné
cette période-ci le jour 15 16 17 18 on
entre dans un espèce de brouillard
justement se demande mais quelle
question j'ai pas déjà posé alors le
fait qu'un collègue vienne nous relayer
ben c'est un nouveau souffle ça permet
aussi comme j'accoudrer le disait de
faire une nouvelle perspective puis des
fois de changer d'air sans dire que les
conférences de presse sont
confrontationnelles mais des fois il y a
des questions qui reviennent
bon les chefs sont peut-être tannés de
les recevoir donc ça permet de
repartir à zéro changement dynamique
c'est ça avec de nouvelles personnalités
autour de nous ça peut faire du bien à
tout le monde je crois et avant de
continuer avec les autres questions j'en
aurai une pour Valérie Sébastien parce
que ce qui est particulier dans votre
cas pour les deux premières semaines de
campagne c'est que vous étiez dans le
même autobus que le chef parce que pour
que les gens comprennent à la maison
généralement pour chaque partie il y a
deux autobus il y a l'autobus du chef il
y a l'autobus avec les médias mais dans
le cas du Parti conservateur et du Parti
québécois il y a un seul autobus
c'est-à-dire que les journalistes
côtoient toujours le chef et son
personnel politique alors je sais pas si
vous pouvez nous expliquer la dynamique
que ça crée parce que parce qu'il y a
une cloison quelque chose qui vous
sépare
je sais pas pour Thomas il y a pas
physiquement il y a pas de cloison avec
le Star il y a pas de porte non il y a
une cloison c'est à dire que les
journalistes on est installés en avant
dans la première portion ensuite il y a
une espèce de petite cuisine
ça y est ça dans tous les autres ce soir
[Rires]
mais pileux après cette cuisine là qui
est aussi le mini bureau imprimante là
il y a le staff politique qui est là il
y a vraiment les organisateurs
coordinateurs de campagne puis après là
il y a une petite loge pour le chef
puis dans cette loge là mais c'est là
qu'il va recevoir c'est candidat c'est
vrai que ces réunions d'équipe c'est là
qui reçoit aussi des anciens ou en tout
cas dans le code du pays est-ce que vous
entendez tous non on n'entend pas sauf
que tu vois tout le temps les gens qui
rentrentissent ok là
on est rendu maintenant à Rimouski
Pascal burbé est encore là parce qu'elle
nous suit jusqu'ici avec le alors que
normalement on verrait pas parce que
la logique fermée mais sauf que tu le
vois passer on voit une partie de
l'astratif
parce que avec le Parti conservateur
c'est un peu la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne teste en avant à notre notre
bureau il y a pas de cuisine comme je
l'ai mentionné mais cloison une porte et
moi c'est une dynamique que j'ai bien
apprécié pendant les deux premières
semaines parce que dès qu'on avait une
question
pour le chef ou pour quelqu'un de son
équipe on avait qu'à cogni à la porte
puis habituellement il y avait pas de
problème peut-être que les chefs
apprécient
parce que dans le compte que du parti
québ ce que c'est qu'on puisse tout de
suite aller les voir puis dire
sincèrement vous êtes il y a quelque
chose là que je comprends pas tu sais
puis ça ça marche pas avec ce que vous
avez déjà dit plus des fois ça prend une
coupe de kilomètres là ils vont se
rassembler avec le chef la question est
réglé pendant une réponse c'est rapide
est-ce que vous êtes senti observé
parfois par l'équipe autour du chef
parce que nous on est dans un autobus
séparé il y a moins cet enjeux là des
fois bon on sent quand même une présence
on fait quand même une présence
quand même mais c'est sûr que tu parles
moins fort
tu as l'impression que quelqu'un
d'avoir le chef dans son autobus
non j'ai trouvé ça comme je disais plus
pratique qu'autre chose mais c'est sûr
que quand on sait qui est derrière puis
qui entend ce qui dit on parle à la télé
donc on sait qu'il va savoir ce qu'on
dit de toute façon non j'ai trouvé ça
plus pratique qu'autre chose moi depuis
de la campagne c'est sûr que puis moi
j'appelle ça les discussions de fin de
journée les discussions de vieux poils
que tu dirais que tu dirais pas
nécessairement en nombre mais comment on
est top besoin des bruits fait que les
collègues
ça
tu parles pas qui entend pas
dans l'autobus stalidaire quand on
voulait pas trop que l'équipe entente on
disait oui la sécurité nautique c'est
très important de changer de code
ok on va changer de code j'aimerais
peut-être que vous nous décriviez
Alexandre jean-coudrais la journée type
d'un caravaning en fait c'est quoi ça
commence quand même tôt le matin ça
finit tard le soir juste pour que les
gens comprennent le travail d'une
journée type avec monsieur Legault je
dirais que depuis le début les journées
se sont beaucoup ressembler à venir
jusqu'à
il y a quelques jours seulement
généralement le départ le matin se
faisait entre 7h30 8h30 une première
annonce qui se faisait assez le taux le
matin et ça vous remarquerez la CAQ
presque chaque jour était le premier
parti à faire son annonce
c'était pas un choix fortuit là c'était
pas parce que monsieur Legault aime plus
ça se vide bonheur que les autres mais
il y avait cette idée-là de partir la
journée avec une annonce qui allait
prendre les devants sur les annonces des
autres parties généralement lors de
cette annonce là qui était présentée en
point de presse on avait donc l'occasion
d'avoir une période de questions ça on
pourra y revenir mais ça chauffait un
petit peu avec l'équipe kakis parce
qu'on était limité dans le nombre de
questions qu'on pouvait poser au début
de la campagne puis ça frottait un peu
avec les journalistes par la suite
souvent un dîner militant donc on se
rendait dans un resto un bar un lieu
public pour rencontrer des gens qui
militent pour la CAQ avec des candidats
locaux et en après-midi généralement on
avait une deuxième annonce il y en a eu
à peu près deux par jour encore une fois
venir jusqu'à il y a quelques jours et
l'après-midi par contre les questions
étaient en formule Scrum donc de presse
ça c'est un peu quand les journalistes
se parlent les uns par dessus les autres
ça devient voilà donc celui qui parle le
plus fort réussit à faire entendre sa
question donc on a eu quand même
beaucoup d'occasions de questionner mais
on n'avait pas d'activités en soirée
avec monsieur Legault on en a eu
honnêtement je pense qu'on en a pas eu
une il y en avait peut-être plus avec
Québec solidaire qui faisait des
rassemblements exactement
je pense que c'est très propre au chef
parce que québeccélère commençait plus
tard beaucoup plus tard ces journées
est-ce que c'est parce que Gabriel a dos
du bois jeune papa passait du temps avec
sa famille c'est peut-être une partie de
l'explication on m'a aussi dit que à
l'époque de Philippe Couillard qui se
levait très tôt les journées
commencaient très tôt mais terminé tôt
également avec Québec solidaire on
commençait plus tard et c'est un peu
comme comme ce qu'Alexandre a dit on
avait une annonce donc on faisait les
annonces à ce moment-là on prenait les
questions des journalistes par la suite
on faisait beaucoup de route il y avait
d'autres activités avec des candidats
justement des rassemblements militants
et Gabriel ado Dubois aussi aime
beaucoup se prêter à l'exercice de
l'Assemblée popular il y en a eu quatre
dans différentes villes souvent ce sont
en territoire déjà conquis mais quand
même il prend des questions du public ça
donne lieu à des échanges donc il y
avait ça et ça c'était souvent soirée
entre 19h et 21h donc peut-être que la
journée se terminait un peu plus tard
mais elle commençait aussi un peu plus
tard le chez Québec solidaire tu vois
nous ça a commencé
tout pq tu sais pas ce message
ça a commencé tout ça finissez le temps
nous on comment ouais les annonces
souvent Intuit et neuf
puis ensuite
le soir rassemblement puis si tu arrives
souvent là quand il est arrivé à 10 en
10 et 11h à l'hôtel des journées de 12
13 14 15 ans finalement c'est vraiment
pas rare en campagne électorale pas mal
non
j'étais avec le Parti libéral et puis je
vais prendre tout de suite une question
d'Alain Lamarre qui est quand même en
lien avec ce qu'on dit là qui veut
savoir si on est restreint un certain
secret politique dans les autobus
secret politique moi je dirais que non
c'est-à-dire qu'on oui il peut y avoir
un embargo par exemple on nous avertit
d'une annonce qui s'en vient pendant du
Bel annonce est à 10h alors avant 10h on
vous demande de pas en parler mais on
vous le donne à l'avance pour que vous
puissiez vous préparer préparer vos
questions mais autrement je sais pas
vous mais moi il y a pas du tout de
secret politique c'est à dire qu'on
rapporte qu'on voit là il peut je veux
dire c'est une réalité de notre métier y
avoir des conversations qui sont off the
record comme on dit j'ai l'impression
que c'est en campagne électorale
ça peut arriver un chef par exemple qui
arrive dans l'autobus qui dit ok là je
vais vous dire
je veux dire bon le fond de la pensée
mais je vous avertis cette discussion
cette discussion là va être puis à
partir de là on a le choix d'accepter ou
non les termes de de cette conversation
là je sais par exemple que durant la
dernière campagne fédérale monsieur
Trudeau s'était présenté dans dans
l'avion devant l'immédiat il y avait
demandé à avoir une conversation of the
week-end je sais qu'il y avait des
médias qui avait refusé de participer à
cette conversation là puisqu'il ne
voulait pas être contraint au secret
politique pour reprendre cette je sais
pas si je cesse bien sans la question de
Monsieur mais on n'a pas eu beaucoup de
moments d'intimité avec le chef François
Legault étant donné qu'on n'est pas sur
le même autobus que lui on l'a vu lors
de ses sorties donc on l'a vu lors de
ses interactions avec les militants avec
les candidats avec les citoyens il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se disent
indépendance ces événements-là mais qui
sont pas forcément d'intérêt public là
Monsieur le goût à quelques reprises il
dit des choses qui étaient très cocasses
c'était rigolo bah vous le connaissez là
comme personnage politique il lui arrive
des fois de dire des choses qui peuvent
drôlement pareil là un moment donné bon
il était dans un rassemblement puis il y
avait un petit garçon une petite fille
qui était là puis bah il y a pensé que
c'était deux petites filles puis là ça
crée un petit malaise sur le coup bah on
voyait le genre mais ça c'est pas
d'intérêt public sauf que il y a pas de
si on a vu de l'intimité des repas
partagés autour d'une table avec le chef
puis que l'oeil c'était ouvert sur sa
perception de certains enjeux ou
certaines choses puis qu'à ce moment-là
ça avait été clair c'est une
conversation of the rocker ben
clairement on aurait respecté cette
entente là mais je peux pas dire qu'il y
a des secrets dont on est au courant
qu'on ne révèle pas en tout cas pas sur
ma caravane il y a des choses qui se il
y a des choses qui je dirais par respect
un moment donné puis là je reviens à on
a fait un article Jacques audre Véro et
moins sur les papas les jeunes papas et
maman les aides parents c'est l'espèce
de concession moi j'ai fait l'entrevue
avec Paul sympa pendant ce moment-là
puis c'est un papa pspb aussi puis là au
début il voulait pas en parler parce
qu'il disait je veux pas pareil comme
d'une victime
alors là il y a comme il y a comme un
truc qui se disait non mais le but le
but c'est
pas ça on veut pas on veut pas on veut
pas dire le but c'est pas que tu as de
l'air du gars qui se plaint puis alors
c'est ça mais c'est pas des secrets
politiques c'est juste des
on entend beaucoup de commentaires
justement surprendre des bébés dans des
fous ça fait partie de la joute
politique entre guillemets et Gabrielle
Nadaud Dubois qu'on entend pas souvent
non plus sur sa vie personnelle lui-même
à vous avoir une certaine pudeur par
rapport à ça et depuis qu'il est chef
parlementaire comporte-parole essaie de
s'ouvrir depuis qu'il est papades
essaient de s'ouvrir un peu à ça donc
à trouver un peu la limite la frontière
aussi entre tout ça puis j'ai William
mcmahiman j'espère que je prononce bien
votre nom qui veut justement poursuivre
le sur ce thème là nous demandant si on
est soumis à un embargo sur certaines
informations au thème mais comme on le
disait à la prochaine conférence de
presse on peut l'être mais il veut
savoir aussi est-ce qu'il y a des choses
que vous avez eu connaissance plutôt en
campagne électorale mais que vous avez
tardé avant d'en parler moi j'aurais
tendance à dire peut-être l'itinéraires
parce que c'est quand même une stratégie
politique des parties leur itinéraire
veulent pas nécessairement que les
adversaires le sachent mais nous on le
sait parce que on doit se préparer là en
terme de logistique mais moi je pense
que dans cette campagne si c'est sa
première fois un truc ça y est je pense
que on avait tous remarqué la sécurité
oui on avait tous remarqué on s'en est
tous pas ma première journée puis on en
a pas parlé tout de suite on a été ouais
c'est ça on a attendu un peu avant d'en
parler puis
ça
ça c'est vrai qu'on a mais je pense tous
mes yeux confondus et plusieurs
on a besoin de savoir à quel endroit on
va dormir le lendemain ou le sur le
lendemain parce que là les gens ne
savent pas forcément mais quand on part
on part en se mettant en tête qu'on part
pour 36 ou 37 jours savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on met dans sa voiture qu'on n'aura
pas la possibilité de faire du lavage
vraiment pendant 36 ou 37 jours donc
dans mon cas de savoir à quelle date je
va passer par Québec pour être capable
de faire du lavage mais le parti va me
le dire mais moi je dirais pas ben on
revient à Québec telle date par contre
il y a quelque chose que je sais pas si
vous l'avez vécu mais justement sur
l'enjeu stratégique de l'itinéraire moi
il est arrivé à deux reprises depuis le
début de la campagne que des Attachés
d'autres autobus me contactent pour me
demander à quelle date ou à quel moment
vous allez être à telle place avec laque
et ça évidemment oui et puis ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça ça indique au
public que nous-mêmes on est soumis à
certaines forces contraires parfois on
tente de nous soutirer de l'information
moi je joue on peut pas jouer dans ce
qu'on peut ouais on peut tester ma
naïveté je crois
mais on peut pas jouer dans ce film là
parce qu'à partir du moment où on
déciderait de dire ah ben je pense
qu'ils vont être à telle place demain là
ça pourrait donner un avantage un
avantage stratégique à l'autre partie
donc clairement on embarque pas
là-dedans il y a certaines choses qu'on
sait et qu'on doit garder pour nous sur
l'itinéraire parce que c'est des enjeux
stratégiques pour les parties
une question de Patrick Laplante qui
nous demande est-ce qu'on a senti une
variation dans l'enthousiasme de
l'équipe qu'on suit depuis le début de
la campagne si oui de quelle nature et
est-ce que vous avez noté un point
tournant c'est sûr que Éric duem quand
il y a plein d'histoires qui sont qui
ont commencé à sortir ça a duré deux
trois quatre jours justement sur ces
taxes non payées et tout ça est-ce que
tu le sentis toi Sébastien dans l'humeur
du chef et son équipe
je dirais d'ambiance à bord de l'autobus
je dis un peu plus tôt que qui était
facile au cours des dernières semaines
d'aller cogner à sa porte puis de lui
poser une question depuis vendredi c'est
un peu moins facile
puis là on a compris bon vendredi quand
cette première histoire est sortie et
parue dans le Journal de Québec à
l'effet qu'il n'avait pas payé ces taxes
foncières ces dernières années il y
avait visiblement un malaise là chez
monsieur duem qui était dans un
rassemblement soir là on lui a demandé
de répondre à nos questions à la caméra
et il y a jamais eu de problème monsieur
James est toujours très euh comment dire
partant ouais c'est ça pour répondre à
nos questions même que dans les
conférences de presse contrairement à
certains autres partis on n'est pas
limité du moins de façon formelle à deux
questions alors que cette fois là il a
accepté de répondre à une question puis
c'est engouffré dans l'autobus
la même chose est arrivé lundi je crois
mardi là quand on a appris maintenant
que c'était cet axe scolaire qui n'avait
pas été payé pendant deux ans là il a
carrément de refusé de répondre à nos
questions avant de s'expliquer le
lendemain alors oui il y a eu un
changement d'atmosphère je dirais un
malaise maintenant on comprend que
c'était dû à la relation qu'il avait
avec son locataire comme il nous l'a
expliqué ou du moins c'est ce qui c'est
ce qu'il a expliqué
j'avais envie de poser la question à
Véronique en fait avec au départ plutôt
difficile est-ce que on la voyait
toujours martelé que ça allait bien tout
ça mais on le sentait quand même en fait
on a tellement une proximité avec les
chefs et le personnel politique que
quand ça va bien on le sent on le voit
automatiquement sur le terrain on est
capable de le rapporter ça paraît même
quand il rencontre les gens dans les
bains de foule il y a beaucoup
d'éléments qui font en sorte qu'on le
voit quand ça va bien beaucoup
d'éléments aussi qui font en sorte qu'on
le voit quand ça va quand ça va moins
bien là c'est même si ils vont pas nous
le dire spécifiquement on le remarque
dans l'attitude il y a aucun doute
là-dessus puis j'aimerais peut-être
qu'on aborde une question parce que je
moi en tout cas personnage je me la fait
souvent posée sur les réseaux sociaux la
question de l'indépendance des
journalistes parfois j'ai l'impression
que les gens pensent qu'on embarque sur
les autobus qu'on va à l'hôtel qu'on se
fait tout payer par le parti alors que
c'est pas le cas donc c'est ça je sais
pas si un de vous veut aborder justement
cet aspect d'indépendance là juste
compléter sur le changement de
changement de temps parce que pour le
particulier c'est
particulier parce que ils ont député la
campagne tu sais tout le monde disait le
parti est mort il va rester un député
c'est Pascal Bérubé puis petit pspp
était pas connu puis là eux c'est le
contraire
semaine où là tu sais dans plusieurs
émissions Paul Saint-Pierre plongeon
était comme l'étoile
on a senti la
le changement le changement d'attitude
puis on a chanté aussi le chef tu sais
ce bombé un peu
me donner
un petit un petit air d'aller alors que
depuis le début on a l'impression que
vraiment il y a eu un air d'aller donc à
l'inverse de toi là moi j'ai vraiment
vécu
une espèce de prise de confiance je
dirais c'est ça qu'on est on est
privilégié d'être au premier loge pour
voir ça là mais comme je le disais on
reste quand même très neutre et
indépendant par rapport au travail qu'on
fait c'est drôle parce que dans un
rassemblement elle est vie un partisan
conservateur qui m'a demandé comment
vous avez choisi
sur quel autobus sur quel caravane
allait se retrouver quel journaliste
est-ce que c'est en fonction de vos
allégeance politiques j'essaie
c'est comme si notre nom avait été dans
un chapeau c'est ça
patron en fait
les gens se posent la question on peine
aux hôtels on peine au repas on paie
pour être sur l'autobus donc c'est pas
comme si c'était eux qui nous payaient
pour être là c'est en fait c'est
l'inverse et on paye nos repas on paye
notre place on paye tout là puis quand
on sent que les relations peuvent
devenir difficiles entre l'équipe du
parti et l'équipe de journalistes il y a
quand même un esprit de corps qui se
forme et je sais pas si vous l'avez
senti sur mon caravane respective sur
divers enjeux mais quand on vit des
problèmes avec le parti qu'on voudrait
peut-être pas nous donner accès à tel ou
tel truc ben on l'exige parce qu'on paye
pour être là on paye pour pouvoir suivre
le chef le travail d'équipe de
journalistes tous médiocre exactement
nous c'est arrivé aussi dans la caravane
solidaire un moment donné on voulait
avoir accès à une deuxième fois à
Gabriel ado Dubois justement il argument
de base ça a été de de se mettre
ensemble puis de dire on perd de
l'argent pour être ici on a une demande
on a des impératifs différents des
vôtres puis vous nous donnez accès à
votre chef une deuxième fois durant la
journée peu importe si vous êtes en
retard ou non c'est pas notre problème
si on est en retard dans l'itinéraire
donc des fois les relations peuvent le
temps peut monter mais au final ça
redevient toujours un peu cordage je
pense que ça fait partie un peu de la
game de la joute
je trouve ça intéressant parce que
particulièrement nous qui sommes à la
télé avant des impératifs logistiques
c'est à dire qu'à 17h et à 18h
actuellement qu'on a des directs on doit
être dans un endroit où on a du réseau
si l'horaire prévoyait qu'on était là
moi j'ai donné rendez-vous à mon
cameraman à cet endroit là et là
finalement 30 minutes plus tôt on dit
finalement on est en retard on a changé
c'est pas que ça qui était prévu puis
après tout ils veulent quand qu'on parle
d'eux tous les journalistes
tout le y en a une partie qui c'est nous
aussi d'ailleurs
[Musique]
sur l'autobus conservateur c'est une
petite anecdote il y a la il y a le
visage de monsieur duem puis on le voit
à travers les fenêtres alors quand je
fais des directs dans l'autobus il y a
Monsieur Jam qui me regarde
j'ai une autre question intéressante de
Patrick Laplante puis peut-être que ça
pourrait être notre dernière question
puis je la trouve très pertinente parce
que je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
qui se le demandent est-ce que la
proximité engendrée par cette expérience
là qu'on vit ça influence notre choix
électoral personnel
je vous demande pas de mentionner pour
qui vous allez voter est-ce que ça peut
effectivement
jouer dans votre tête
ça joue dans la perception qu'on a des
personnages politiques des politiques
des politiciennes qu'on suit le monsieur
le goût que je vois au quotidien c'est
pas le monsieur le goût que je voyais à
l'Assemblée nationale donc j'ai
découvert des aspects de sa personnalité
que je ne soupçonnais pas
de là à dire puis je m'en vais avec les
libéraux de la dire que la personnalité
que je perçois chez le chef au quotidien
pourrait influencer ce que moi comme
citoyen je ferai comme choix le 3
octobre non
plus vigilante en fait encore d'être
vraiment là-dedans puis de pas se
laisser
spinner comme on dit dans le dans le
jargon
j'ai l'impression que moi ça me rend
plus vigilante puis je ressens même si
j'avais déjà entendu Sébastien bavé
parlé du fait qu'il l'annulait son vote
lui parce qu'il jugeait trop proche puis
j'ai l'impression que je me sens aussi
peut-être des fois un peu comme ça je me
sentirais trahir un peu mon travail en
choisissant le 3 octobre
je suis pas d'accord avec Sébastien là
je pense que c'est un devoir de
citoyenne de voter et je compte remplir
mon devoir mais
personnellement ça fait quand même
quelques campagnes que je fais puis je
pense que ça a jamais influencé mon vote
moi je suis d'accord avec toi moi c'est
ce que j'allais dire parce que ça nous
fait prendre conscience de des efforts
du temps que mettent pas seulement les
chefs mais ceux qui l'accompagnent
quand on arrive à la fin de la campagne
ils sont remplis d'espoir puis parfois
ils t'ont ils sont déçus parfois ils
sont contents ça nous permet de
comprendre ce qu'ils ont ce qui est en
jeu en fait ce soir-là ils ont un petit
peu une campagne électorale tu étais
tellement privilégié d'avoir les deux
chapeaux de journalistes puis des
lecteurs parce que quand tu arrives le 3
octobre tu es probablement parmi les
mieux renseignés pour faire ton X et moi
je suis d'accord avec avec Véronique ça
demeure un devoir de citoyens et puis au
contraire c'est
c'est qu'on est bien outils pour faire
ce choix là parce qu'on voit aussi on le
sent l'autisme caravanes on voit les
dynamiques puis on les programmes on n'a
pas le choix de mettre le nez dedans
puis exactement peut-être un petit
rappel avant de partir juste nous dire
j'encouru avec le Parti conservateur de
ce soir Alexa les extrêmes politiques
c'est ça
moi je reste dans un parti
indépendantiste souverainisme parce que
je rejoins donc Québec solidaire pour le
reste de la campagne et moi j'ai été
avec le parti libérale et je m'en vais
maintenant avec la coalition et Québec
alors je remercie tout le monde de nous
avoir écouté nous avoir donné cette
opportunité parce que chacun dans nos
autobus je pense qu'on avait besoin de
parler
rapide ça fait du bien d'en parler en
groupe de se voir en personne alors ça
va être le premier débat ce soir on va
surveiller ça merci tout le monde de
nous avoir suivis si vous avez d'autres
questions vous pouvez nous les envoyer
par courriel par Twitter par Facebook
nos adresses personnelles ça va nous
faire plaisir de répondre
bye merci
[Musique]